because most reality TV shows are about
as authentic as a $3 bill lots of these
series will often bring in experts on
various subjects to boost the
credibility History Channel's Pawn Stars
often makes use of specialists to
themselves and become quite famous
thanks to frequent appearances these men
and women can help determine whether a
big-ticket item is the real deal or just
a piece of junk but who are they really
here's a look at what you don't know
about the experts on Pawn Stars Bob
Yuhas an antiques restorer who first
appeared on Pawn Stars during season 8
Bob Yuhas specializes in restoring
repairing and the conservation of
antiques in his own words he can make
old things look new and new things look
old Yuhas restoration abilities are no
joke although his line delivery could
use a little work just 140 years ago
old-world friendship which is odd
because in addition to us has worked
with antiques he's also an actor if
you're a fan of the Food Network reality
series mystery diners he might look
familiar he appeared in an episode
titled nightshift as the bloody of a
late-night bartender that was supposedly
undermining his unsuspecting boss we say
supposedly because his radar online
reveals the show was busted for fakery
with Pawn Stars dodging his own
accusations of staging Bob Yuhas his
addition to the series list of experts
feels somewhat ironic Bill's agree knows
specializing in collecting and restoring
classic vehicles fill three notes runs
the underground garage where he fixes up
awesome rides like his signature 1967
Volkswagen bus the fourth green house
appeared on Pawn Stars his love of cars
played out on the bill goldberg hosted
reality TV show known as bull run where
he and his brother george successfully
auditioned to appear during the second
season the brothers raced their 1967
Volkswagen bus against 11 other teams
sadly they didn't win while Pawn Stars
fans knows the green O's primarily for
his love and knowledge about old cars
there is another industry for which he's
known tiles see green O's founded t
brothers tile a company specializing in
tile granite laminate wood carpet window
coverings and water jet cutting services
the company claims they've installed
more than 26 million square feet of tile
enough to cover just over 450 football
fields dr. Phineas T castle one can't
help but instantly become a fan of the
charmingly eccentric dr. Phineas V
castle better known as dachshund Ian
when the guys upon stars have no idea
whether an item is authentic or even
what the heck it is Phineas is the
expert they bring in to figure it out in
addition to his vast knowledge of
antiques doc Phineas is a huge steampunk
fan so much so that he helped produce
the Las vegas-based demuth on a
weekend-long celebration of all things
steampunk although known as Doc Phineas
he could technically change his name to
professor according to Phineas he's
taught college classes for over 45 years
doc Phineas is also an actor singer and
he's known to dance every now and then
to rock on Doc Shawn rich the owner of
Tortuga trading Shawn rich is an antique
arms and armor specialist as well as an
expert on shipwrecked treasure this may
be why Disney turned rich when filming
Pirates of the Caribbean he was generous
enough to lease and sell items for the
making of a second than third movie and
he also provided props for AMC's
American Revolution based drama turn
rich appeared on the Pawn Stars series
in 2011
but then walked away because according
to rich both the Pawn Stars producer and
the History Channel required an
exclusive contract rich said the
contract was locked me down control me
like business future my appearance how
to make a living to provide for my
family in 2013 rich opted to hop over to
National Geographic the host and star in
the series Lords of war the History
Channel must have come around eventually
because he returned to Pawn Stars in
2014 Jesse Omarosa Pawn Stars vintage
musical instrument and amplifier
specialist Jesse Amoroso happens to own
the famous Cowtown guitars Amoroso and
his wife Roxy who also appears at
Cowtown were known locally for their
sleeves rock band Pegasus before buying
cow sound in 2011 fun facts cow town was
actually founded in 1990 by Bob Seger
touring guitarist mark Chatfield
countdown has thrived under the
ownership of Amoroso thanks in part to
the celebrity he's gained as a
frequently featured expert on
Caan stars the booming business might be
why Amuro so ultimately decided to
relocate
he's now within walking distance of the
legendary gold and silver pond through
Cowtown Amoroso happens to own one of
the largest collections of vintage
instruments in North America for a true
music lover it doesn't get much better
than that Jeremy brown it seems pretty
common for Pawn Stars experts to
relocate their businesses to be closer
to gold and silver pot Jeremy Brown the
shows go to sports memorabilia guy moved
his ultimate sport cards and memorabilia
business in 2012 Brown's business was
doing pretty well for itself before he
made the big move but he said he wanted
to fully embrace the opportunity that
the show has provided and be near other
fellow experts Brown said that his life
as a sports memorabilia experts began
with an addiction to collecting baseball
cards according to Sports collectors
daily Brown fields working with Pawn
Stars is an absolute blessing as the
show allows him to share his love of
sports memorabilia with millions of
people Steve grab a professional sports
Authenticator who appeared on Pawn Stars
between 2013 and 2014
Steve Greg I caught up in some
embarrassing controversies that make it
very unlikely he'll reappear on the show
anytime soon the trouble started when
Grant found himself at the center of a
2011 lawsuit apparently his company has
tried to pass off a signature as
belonging to famed aviator Charles
Lindbergh Lindbergh's own daughter came
forward with an expert and successfully
challenged the claim it turned out grads
expert opinion had lost collectors
hundreds of thousands of dollars after
he allegedly approved scores of
forgeries as legitimate and it gets
worse
despite heavily implying that he'd been
educated at the prestigious Columbia
School of Journalism further research
determined the grad had actually
attended Columbia College Chicago
instead and he never even graduated in
fact during a court-ordered deposition
he had revealed he'd received no formal
training of any kind back up his expert
limp he instead credits much of what he
knows being mentored by the king of
memorabilia bill massarone
a man who landed in prison after being
busted for various acts of fraud mark
hall-patton unlike fraud Steve grad mark
hall-patton was
knives by the los angeles time as the
real deal hall-patton is the museum
administrator for the Clark County
Museum system although nicknamed the
beard of knowledge he readily admits
that if he doesn't know something he's
always ready to perform detailed
research most of us would turn to Google
but hall-patton can also pull facts from
his personal library of over 20,000
books
he's appeared on close to 100 episodes
of Pawn Stars making him one of the
show's better known experts his wife dr.
Colleen hall-patton wrote a celebrity
studies article on her husband's sudden
fame and he even has a group of fanboys
in the Washington State Penitentiary and
sometimes for fun he pretends to be a
zombie no really Stewart Lutz appearing
on Pawn Stars during a safe season
stewart loves authenticates historic
documents manuscripts and letters and
he's also one of the few experts to be
granted the seal of approval by the
appraisers Association of America he in
the field on books and manuscripts in
historic documents plus has an online
catalogue of historic documents
autographs letters and manuscripts and
also owns one of just three authentic
castings of President Eisenhower's hands
something that's either really awesome
or really creepy we can't quite decide
Lutz wrote the last leaf a book about
the last known survivors to witness
major historical events or interact with
now to see celebrities that's kind of
morbid Brett maily a fine art appraiser
who appeared on Pawn Stars between 2010
and 2014
Brett mailee also earned a bit of
celebrity for his 2011 appraisal of an
authentic Andy Warhol sketch which was
purchased for just $5 at a garage sale
not content to leave the fine art world
to the rich Meili published a 2014 book
called the pocket picker for fine art
which features a foreword pinned by Pawn
Stars Rick Harrison the book is meant to
help the average person secure and
profit from fine art and avoid selling
off rare art that they happen to own for
a meager five bucks
interestingly long before his current
highbrow occupation Meili worked as a DJ
for cool 105.5 in Florida where he was
often responsive
for radio voiceovers and board operation
so that's pretty random
Rebecca Romney the only female expert
featured on Pawn Stars bibliophile
Rebecca Romney's expertise is rare and
antiquarian books and documents but
there's a bit more to her than dusty old
text in addition to English she speaks
French and Japanese fluently and can
actually read six languages including
Latin ancient Greek and Old English and
in case you're not impressed by that Old
English actually looks and sounds like
this
so features Seulong histah Tish and
Sunna she also hosted a reddit asked me
anything in 2014 during which she
admitted to going on double dates with
Pawn Stars Rick Harrison and she once
brought building on the Pawn Stars set
to a halt because a rare book wasn't
being handled properly
now that's a bibliophile Marisol Chuck
better known as magic Marie Marie
sawchuck is easily distinguishable from
the other experts thanks to his spiky
bleached blond hair style the celebrity
magician and sunny man is called pond
from time to time to give his expert
opinion on all sorts of magical items
the self-proclaimed Dennis the Menace of
magic is no stranger to the reality TV
show circuit he also made appearances on
both America's Got Talent and the
reality dating series blind date which
details his magical search for love
hello hey although things didn't work
out with Georgia magic Marie did
eventually find love with Britain's Got
Talent performer Chloe Crawford and the
couple were married in 2012 sadly a few
years later Crawford dumped him for
rival illusionist Criss Angel harsh
well they say what goes around comes
around and Crawford was reportedly
dumped by angel less than a year after
she left Sasha
looks like these magicians know how to
make a relationship disappear Mathew see
Shortell he claims to be an expert on
all things military and aviation and
math you see Shortell definitely has the
resume to back it up not only did he
achieve the rank of lieutenant colonel
in the United States Marines Shortell is
also a former u.s. Navy Blue Angel pilot
and an honest-to-goodness graduate of
the elite Top Gun
Oh Graham additionally Shortell is an
avid triathlon competitor and it's
competed in Ironman 70.3 as part of a
team he sounds like he feels the need
for speed I feel thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]